cancelled christmas markets closed shops
protesters demonstrating against coveted
restrictions
these images look a lot like scenes from
2020 with the difference that today most
people in these countries have been
fully vaccinated
governments have doubled down on efforts
to leave the pandemic behind and yet
the messaging was take the two shots and
we'll reopen societies and that turned
out to be sort of a false promise
because science developed further it
kind of emerged that it's it's not
sufficient
immunity from vaccines wanes over time
in germany more than 45 percent of
people hospitalized for covid are fully
vaccinated
many people are also still hesitant to
get their shots and the cold weather
isn't helping as immune systems are
weaker in the winter
in the us infections are on the rise
officials have said they want to avoid
draconian measures we can curb the
spread of the virus
without having to
in any way shut down our economies but
what's happening in europe shows how
hard it still is to keep the pandemic
under control
protests broke out across central and
eastern europe after governments
announced renewed restrictions
austria was the first european country
to reimpose a nationwide lockdown and
officials in countries like germany and
italy also reintroduced some
restrictions
imposing vaccine requirements and
stopping unvaccinated citizens from
accessing most public spaces
in germany the vaccination rate is 68
compared to 59 in the us
but infections are still surging
there is a disagreement as to what
proportion of the population you need to
vaccinate in order to feel that society
is kind of safe they're talking about 80
75 perhaps more than that it's it's
difficult to know but essentially it
needs to be more than two-thirds
but even fully vaccinated people are
getting sick and it's largely because
immunity against covet from vaccines
begins to wane after around four months
when the vaccines were actually created
there was a different type of virus
circulating in the global population and
it turns out that the delta variant is
more aggressive and spreads more easily
more infectious it's hugely beneficial
to get the vaccine but it's not enough
at the moment to stop the pandemic from
being a menace to society at large
so countries are looking to roll out
booster shots to increase people's
protection against the virus
so far just 6.8 percent of people in
europe have received their booster shots
which scientists say is a fraction of
the percentage needed to keep the virus
under control
in the u.s around 19 of adults had
received a booster vaccine as of
november
and the widespread implementation of a
vaccine mandate is looming
as the weather gets cooler across the
northern hemisphere people are moving
indoors where the virus tends to
circulate faster
more people are also crowding into
airports and traveling during the
holidays which epidemiologists say could
also increase the risks of other covert
surges the seasonality of the virus
which is now assumed to be a feature of
this disease has hit really hard
and as cold weather spreads across
europe cases are skyrocketing
and governments are forced into various
measures that they sort of promised they
wouldn't be resorting to again
officials have said that they wanted to
avoid implementing renewed lockdowns we
are not headed in that direction but
even as deaths and hospitalizations are
down from last year as long as cases are
going up and people are getting sick
governments like those in europe are
having to adapt to the pandemic which
seems to be here to stay one lesson we
can really learn from all this is that
whatever governments have said earlier
about
not being able to ever do something
again that's not really you can't take
it at face value because essentially
they can say whatever they like
and the virus will force them to do
something that's necessary